come out of a briefing in the last
couple of minutes and what Clarence
House is saying is the following they're
saying that Prince Charles has been
heirs to the throne for forty years in
that role he has had about 600 official
engagements every year he has met
countless number of experts countless
number of members of the public and they
say he is in a unique position in this
country to offer opinions on a whole
variety of subjects they say that he
cares passionately about this country
about people and about the world and if
he can offer his help then he is willing
to do so they've issued a statement this
is what they say the Prince of Wales
cares deeply about this country and
tries to use his unique position to help
others he's devoted most of his working
life to helping individuals and
organizations to make a difference for
the better of this country and the world
now this statement goes on to say that
government ministers have often
encouraged him to have a dialogue with
them many have welcomed the prince's
views and ideas on a whole range of
subjects it goes on to say the Prince of
Wales believes as have successive
governments that he should have a right
to communicate privately the publication
of private letters can only inhibit his
ability to express the concerns and
suggestions which have been put to him
in the course of his travels and his
meetings I guess ultimately this will
have a damaging effect on Clarence House
I think it certainly has bruised the
Prince of Wales although seeing him
today he was smiles all round as he met
various young people on a number of
those engagements that I spoke about so
I think it has been a difficult period
it's not the result Clarence House
wanted but they have put up a very
robust defense and they've also given us
a whole list of detail about each of the
letters that were written the reasons
behind the prince writing them and the
conclusions that were drawn